[Music]
azar hello Ruby Nia a month sir your new
kid on the block
I am against we love stuff I think so
there is some that have been here for
years but actually the ones that were
here The Kooks they have recently left
and I mean how would you describe them
as bosses um different than any I've
ever had yeah
anyway let's order um obviously was
gonna dance or wine hopefully selling
local having just driven through those
amazing vineyards but there's nothing
local yeah no I mean New Zealand 7-yard
blah I where's I have always recommend
for lunch what's the soup today the soup
is a minestrone oh that's good yeah B
C's bacon burger yeah let's do a pizza
as well oh sorry actually we don't do
the pizzas any longer I don't know why
they pages not taken out Wow okay
anything else it's not on we are out of
the pork stir-fry and we do not have
chili no chili let's do a prime rib as
well with that shall we I believe we're
out of remember a valise throwing out
there on Turkey ciabatta yep it's
usually a good one let's just do a
turkey dip I'm hold on a minute breaking
news
bc seem to be famous teriyaki steak does
that mean when someone says soon to be
famous who writes the author may soon be
famous would that be on the menu I think
we should try it
let's go I think we're done okay yeah
sure yeah thank you
okay I do need help
mr. nice a right Wow that doesn't even
taste homemade it's frozen frozen
minestrone soup yeah we brought the BC
bacon burger ten days
what onion rings thicker than my pate Oh
were they from
I'll find out that answer on the
hamburgers it says on the menu Certified
Angus beef where do we get that are they
fresh or frozen no we always come back
that's frozen 25 let's have a coat and
the the patties bland actually tastes
frozen please do it does come frozen so
it says fresh and it's not anywhere near
$13 for that the food coming I was very
good this is the turkey no thank you
what's this here that is the broth for
the turkey sandwich
just a little sip Wow
so salty yes salty and bitter Jesus you
want to taste this actually he had me
tasted and it's really salty goodness
healthy yeah [ __ ] here is the teriyaki
chicken the Navy famous burger what is
that was he doused in teriyaki over
cheese Oh nearly famous this is bad to
be famous to send me to the bathroom
yeah I mean I'm I'm here to go there
nope
I deserve a coffee okay